لكن رغم كل ذلك اليوم وغدا يبدو الوضع
مغيرا ستصبح افريقيا مركز المستقبل الحضري
للعالم وقد تعود مصانع الاستعمار
فبحلول عام 2000 و100 سوف يكون 50% من
مواليد في العالم من المواليد في العالم
من افريقيا وستكون 13 مدينه حضريه من اصل
20 في العالم داخل افريقيا بينها لاغوس
والخرطوم ومن باصه
بحسب عده دراسات حديثا نشرتها واشنطن بوست
وكل ما ارتفعت اعداد سكان المدن كبورات
اسواقها وبالتالي ازداد استثمار الاجانب
والاستثمار الاجنبي المباشر في افريقيا
وقفز اصلا الى من تسعه مليار دولار في عام
2000 الى 83 مليار دولار في عام 2021 على
الرغم منها هذا العام كان جميع يعاني من
تداعيات جائحه كرومنه 2021 لكن هذا الصعود
له تحدياته
القاره محاصره بالفساد ومعرضه بشده
للاضطرابات السياسيه والداخليه بجانب خطر
الحركات الارهابيه بالطبع لكن المستقبل
القريب يبدو افضل فنسبه الاشخاص الذين
يعيشون تحت خط الفقر في افريقيا
سينخفض من 34% في
2022 الى
26% في 2030 وذلك بحسب والدلاب قوه بشريه
وطموح اقتصاده سيتماشا مع نفوذ افريقيا
السياسيه فهي تمتلك 54 مقعدا في الامم
المتحده يمثلون اكثر من ربع العدد
الاجمالي
[موسيقى]